now to growing concerns about the deadly
coronavirus officially hitting the u.s
one person with coronavirus in king
county washington state has died
so it's been two years since the first
case of covid was detected in the u.s
and we've had a major scientific
breakthrough since then vaccines
antivirals
probably what's most significant in the
background is genomic sequencing
that's the work that's been done by
scientific labs to figure out what
mutations people have of coronavirus and
what those mutations do when they do
infect a person
it's really to help adapt vaccines
really quickly and prevent that strain
from doing a significant amount of
damage
i headed out to seattle where they had
detected the first case of kovat in the
community to ask the scientists who've
been on the front line of covitt
detection and mutation surveillance are
we any better prepared
yes sorry this question makes me really
mad
i'm hoping we've learned a lot of
lessons
so we're in downtown seattle when i
started thinking through the question of
how do we assess whether or not we're
any better prepared for the next
pandemic
all my reporting actually led here and
basically the reason seattle was so
prepared by the time coronavirus came
along is they'd already started a
project called the seattle flu study it
started in 2018 and by 2019 they were
doing this swab and send program where
people could take a nasal swab which you
probably had never thought of doing
before the coronavirus pandemic but
people were doing it here just to figure
out what kind of respiratory illnesses
were circulating in the community
because they were in this position and
they were doing this work they found the
first case of community-acquired covid
in the u.s
we're here to talk to the scientists who
came up with that project and who are
hopefully going to see that through and
perhaps expand it
hair ties
so the seattle flu study started in 2018
and at the time we called this the
seattle flu study mainly because when
everybody is sick in the winter they
think they have the flu even if they
don't and secondly you know as a
prototype pandemic preparedness platform
you know everybody thought the next
pandemic would be a flu or an influenza
so these are these are samples from the
seattle chronic virus assessment network
we're interested in what's going on in
the community with people who are
infected with some respiratory pathogen
they're not sick enough to go to the
doctor
what do they have and can we
can we find it
so when somebody signs up for the
seattle flu study usually it's because
you know they've woken up with some sort
of illness the person you know follows
the instructions to swab themselves and
put that swab safely in a tube in a
specimen bag we test it for covid and 20
something other pathogens
we
found out about coronavirus just like
everybody else through the news we
immediately saw that hey if we just turn
on a test for coronavirus at the same
time we could be screening for all of
these things to understand what
coronavirus looks like in the community
right now
there was already a massive outbreak in
europe there was kind of no way that it
wasn't here already we just weren't
looking
so it was really not surprising at all
and we found one within the first 400
samples we ran
the results of the sequencing that labs
like leah's get go into bigger systems
that then feed into a program called
next stream that was created by trevor
bedford so tell us what we're looking at
here oh boy uh
so um so here we can see the viruses
that were collected over the course of
the pandemic trevor's work focuses on
where mutations are and how they spread
around the world and it's work that he's
done for other diseases particularly flu
and that's part of the work that gets
done to like help build the new flu
shots and also work that's been adapted
to tuberculosis
ebola even zika so it's the kind of
genomic and scientific sequencing data
taken to the next level and shown in
that real world here's where the threats
are here's where the virus is emerging
kind of way
there's many countries many geographies
that didn't have any any sequencing and
now they're sequencing
thousands of viruses every month
and this is yeah this is a huge step
into the future
how this whole thing works how this
genomic surveillance works is that right
now people will get tested for
coronavirus each of those
swabs will result in a 30 000 letter
genome and so each of the samples will
have slightly different mutations in
those 30 000 letters
and he use that to look for variants
that are emerging and how they're
spreading and kind of learn a lot about
both the evolution and epidemiology of
the virus
so this is
viruses that are currently circulating
that were collected from the very early
pandemics so this is going to be wuhan
in january 2020 the first sequencing was
really helpful to establish human human
spread so this was at a time when china
was downplaying human human spread but
chinese scientists were openly sharing
their sequencing data and after that
point the sequencing was really helpful
to understand how it was spreading
around the world and then subsequent
it's been really helpful to understand
variants and and their spread and
whether one virus is more transmissible
than another virus
basically if we can get the whole world
to be having the ability to
detect and sequence covid it would give
us a head start in terms of when the
next pandemic is emerging as it could
emerge from from anywhere
my intentions are and to the extent that
i could have any influence on it there
will be a broad
comprehensive approach
to pandemic preparedness and response at
every level
i mean there have been calls
recently for increased pandemic
preparedness and building
more capacity one might imagine in a
future where there's a lot of great you
know respiratory disease surveillance
people having a swab in their home and
when they got that cough they would you
know swab themselves and then send that
back to the lab and they could test for
multiple pathogens that
would make a big difference my goal is
to try to make this stuff a heck of a
lot cheaper so that we can kind of
perform this sort of surveillance
without breaking the bank like we've
been doing for the last couple of years
i'm just
worried that before we can build
something like that on a national scale
the political will evaporate and the
appropriations will evaporate with it
it's the work that's going on when
there's not a pandemic that really
prepares us for pandemics and that
probably sounds fairly obvious but it's
really important to stop and realize
that we don't always fund that research
for us to be really prepared and
building better vaccines that protect us
against threats that exist
we really need to be paying for basic
research to be going on all the time
without this kind of funding so much
amazing scientific work could sit on
shelf
that's really unfortunate
scientists in south africa are warning
of a new strain of covid19 the variant
which is yet to be named appears to have
a high number of mutations
in the weeks after going to seattle
omicron emerged and it's remarkable when
you think about the speed at which the
information about omicron was made
available
had we not been sequencing and had we
not discovered omicron we would have
just experienced a surge in covet cases
with no reason and we would have had no
understanding about that and the reason
some of this is possible is because of
private money actually in public health
hi rick
there you are
welcome to us
rick bright worked in government in
several different positions he was a
whistleblower under the trump
administration he came out publicly to
air his concerns about how the trump
administration was handling pandemic
preparedness our economy is spiraling
downward and our population is being
paralyzed by fear stemming from a lack
of a coordinated response and a dearth
of accurate clear communication about
the path forward but he's since rejoined
the biden covid transition team
and now is part of the rockefeller
foundation and he's heading up their
pandemic preparedness institute i think
governments move slowly they want to um
check and double check they want to you
know evaluate things and they want to be
absolutely certain before they pull
those triggers and i saw that with that
the murs outbreak with the h1n1
influenza outbreak with that zika
outbreak we've seen this repeatedly
we need to have
entities in place and organizations in
place in our country
that can be less risk averse
that can be more nimble and flexible so
the world can know what's happening and
scientists and the public can be able to
better respond to those newly emerging
variants do we have enough sequencing
and is it rapid enough for us to be able
to enact public health measures to
really stem the tide of another wave of
serious infections
genomic surveillance alone
can't do much
but genomic surveillance and sequencing
data is a powerful data set that we can
use to target
resources to areas where we know there
will be a surge in virus to bolster the
hospital systems to make sure there are
sufficient medical supplies in those
areas where we might
see that virus emerging genomic
surveillance is a powerful leading
indicator that will allow us to target
our medical countermeasures and our
health care response the biden
administration announced 1.7 billion for
improved sequencing
data sharing
is it enough money do we need more money
to really build the kind of systems that
we would say
really have put the safeguards in place
that we need you know it was a lot of
money i don't think the money has been
distributed fully i don't think is being
distributed fast enough and we will be
fighting this pandemic in the rear view
mirror until we get in front of
a solid robust surveillance system that
will also target
vaccine breakthrough and re-infection
cases our vaccines are amazing they're
wonderful they're doing a wonderful job
until they don't
and it's in those few cases
when they don't
where we really need to harness that
genomic surveillance capability to ask
why
we've made a lot of progress don't
discount that at all
my biggest concern though cynthia is all
of these things that we've learned
even the things that we've done to make
improvements
could just as easily be forgotten the
day after this pandemic ends we need to
make sure
that we're taking every step
to dig in and implement these new things
that we're learning for
a new normal going forward beyond the
pandemic
are we more prepared yes and no i think
we know what we need to do
and that's you know half the battle at
least we know that we need we need to be
stockpiling supplies to build
tests we know that testing is really
important we know that surveillance is
really important
but i am
not sure
that
we're going to be able to do that in a
nimble fashion but i think science is
ready
there are reasons to be optimistic when
you think about pandemic preparedness
now as compared to two years ago i think
we do have a lot more sequencing
capability in the us and in the world
than we did previously and a lot more of
the scientific work is getting done
but
probably what's critically missing here
is the sustainability of funding
and i think the other thing that we
really need to consider and make sure
that is constantly in this conversation
is
the benefits of sequencing are tailoring
the vaccine to make sure that it's more
effective
so we need sequencing going on all over
the world but we need the benefits of
that sequencing to also flow through to
the people who are providing that
scientific information
that those countries are also getting
the vaccine and making sure that it
really benefits
the whole world not just a small sliver
you